schneller wenn der Flieger geht gleich
hey der Flieger führt erst wenn der
Erwin so dass der Flieger jetzt wird
Scheiße die haben schon zur
[Gelächter]
hier ist die Gepäckschalter für den Flug
nach Teneriffa schön dass ich noch
geschafft habe den Koffer bitte
komisch und dieser Kleiderschrank
auf den Kanaren hat das ganzjährig
mindestens 20 Grad aber wir fahren auf
Teneriffa nicht auf die kanarienschlucht
mal helfen oder bloß blöd rumstehen
die waren Schnaps erst die Ausweise
bitte
was willst du jetzt unseren Ausweis ist
doch klar dass mir mir sagen sonst wäre
man doch wer anders
wissen Sie ich will nicht nach Teneriffa
hier
ist er doch
brauchst nur unseren Familienstammbaum
oder Auri bitte nicht also eigentlich
werden wir jetzt fertig es gibt ein
kleines Problem sie haben 20 Kilo
Übergewicht ich werde nicht lange
359 99
sie haben jetzt genau zwei Möglichkeiten
sie lehren jetzt sofort 20 kg aus ihrem
Koffer oder oder Sie schauen sich den
Riff im Fernsehen an gibt da ganz tolle
Dokus okay und davor schon Programm
[Musik]
Durchsage für alle Passagiere von Carbon
fly an unserem Check-in-Schalter gibt es
derzeit längere Wartezeiten wir bitten
mir Verständnis wir bitten mir
Verständnis
geht so hey ihr zieht sich laut
nicht
den ganzen Betrieb
[Applaus]
jetzt verstehen wir uns letzte Woche für
eine Passagiere es nach Teneriffa der
Flug schließt in
genau
[Applaus]
[Musik]